hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to soma now we're
wandering through the vents about to go
into the laboratory I imagine oh those
are fun sounds what's that my heart
beating do I even have a heart there's
that there's a sense of style you didn't
god I can't say those words because I
have a little bit of a list but I can't
even think before us synthesized idea of
a heart beating in my chest or maybe
that's just my heart being fed through
everything else
hello well that looks comforting okay
someone's in pain in the other room and
I'm about to find out why why does it
sound like something's crawling behind
me I mean I'm assuming this is me
dragging my big metal body across the
great here but I don't know hello
oh this looks laboratory as' oh hey
how's it going
Boop Oh someone mentioned that this
actually heals me and then all damage I
take is actually permanent until I get
to these locations and heal so I did not
know that I guess it was some benefit to
having all of this goopy stuff all over
me
unless I don't know if that's true okay
Catherine your problems huh wait
Oh No Wow got to the done back before we
did right yeah I was talking that's
rarely a good sign
damn it the dumb bet was our best shot I
was really banking on this to work huh
we can't quit now there's got to be
another way how do you think you did it
how did the team get the art down the
abyss in the first place if they didn't
use the done bad the only other way
would be the climber and omicron it's
like an elevator which supposedly
reaches all the way down into the abyss
supposedly we do that we go to Omicron
and take the elevator yeah okay sure
we'll just head over to Omicron and hope
there's a power suit that fits you you
know so you don't implode while in the
abyss that that sounds useful all right
let's go then push cool what is this
place
seems to be a lot of information on the
art here there's a prototype in
everything okay
let's start it up I want to see how it
works maybe we can figure out how to get
on the ark okay that would be nice and
all but there seems to be something Oh
did you do them know how to get a song I
mean pretty difficult if it's a complex
machine that's got to have a bunch of
things happening to it I've decided to
finalize the Ark with the skins we have
I'm sorry for all of you wanted to go
but didn't get a chance to scan yourself
before the project was put on hold
it's been two months since I've added a
scan and I don't see how I'll ever be
able to win back the support you all
showed when we started the project I'm
sorry I never meant for anyone to take
their lives it was never my intention to
fool anyone I just wanted to save
something apply interface module CLR
castle ask permission from 4q brief of
Ashkan tech shuttle pick up our suit
treadclimber regroup at tau at launch
site load the bullet launch arc okay
that sounded like a good plan the arc is
currently somewhere here Oh key dokie
then to gauge staff opinion please fit
Oh another survey I can't wait
recently it was decided that the arc
project would become pathos whose last
official commitment the staff has been
urged to carry on with their duties
despite earth cadet catastrophic
condition I think the arc project is the
most logical step towards saving mankind
we should spend about time and resources
that we need to complete it sure I only
slightly agree I don't strongly agree to
embark every passenger needs to be flush
with electromagnetism using a pilot see
these scanning sessions are only are
known to cause nausea and headaches
lasting up to three days I think
temporary physical discovering how no
matter how severe is a small browser I
agree the ark is built to fit a range
around kv7 broom the meaning it could be
shot in space with the Omega space got
integrally survivors out here let me up
little bubble Irvine I think the earth
should leave earth behind and be
launched into space
would it be better in space and it would
be on earth I guess under the ocean
isn't exactly a good place to be in
depending on devastate the surface of
the earth is I don't have enough
information to do that I choose the
middle button baby to boobity boobity
boobity would disagree the
digitalization of humanity is an
opportunity to make a quantum leap in
our own evolution the people inside the
ark will be out of necessity be
generated from the existing genetic code
but could be altered to allow for
cosmetic changes ease aging and even
prevent death I think we're a risk of
losing our humanity if we rid ourselves
of disease and mortality Oh
strongly agree absolutely there are only
58 people alive to be stored inside the
ark away to diversify and expand the
population would be in reserve because
you appear to be human but with
childlike and naive sensibilities as we
continue to explore well does that seem
like a good idea I think even an
inferior group of artificial people
would benefit our society I don't think
he's as much as that do you do know that
seems like bad that seems like how the
Wow was made in the first place okay
what did I do okay agree hey I disagreed
not many people disagreed Wow my choices
don't seem to be in the popularity huh
okay all right well those my choices in
that's what I got I don't know what
these numbers mean okay Ruby okay
everybody the whole girl
yay really who are you saving this for
the world was dead
thanks Simon I thought being in the
[ __ ]
wasn't invented until second century now
I know there yeah yeah okay alright that
was instructions should I have read
those I need to put on a power seat but
it doesn't exactly matter because I am a
robot to move me to be able to move so
it doesn't really matter what I do
okay so I got to find a way to get the
things and they need to do what's this
thing can I step inside
cool I'm done trying I'm totally down
I'm all about this HP on switch no we
it's like being at the airport and
having my privacy invaded worried about
radiation they think we're beyond that
interesting you seem to be one with the
diving suit you're wearing
everything's meshed together how's that
gonna work with the suit we're picking
up at Omicron um I think the bigger you
should be able to wear the both energy
who's that it looks like the basis for
your body is one my old colleagues a
standard cortex chip for robots
including the data reader and the acute
or CH has just been forced through the
skull what structure gel is fused the
whole construction together an amazing
staff no no no hold on back up I'm one
of your old colleagues well your body is
Imogen Reed it's disgusting hey don't
say that she's mine she was nice to me
anyway the cortex chip is good news that
means we can transfer your mind to the
Ark with a pilot see ya I'm half a dead
person yes it makes sense think about it
all those simplistic minds we've run
into just reviving a dead person doesn't
seem to work that well a robot body
seems to make people a bit unreliable
you are the best of both worlds
sound mind in a sound body okay that's
even weirder than I thought it'd be a
concept but I don't know I really wish
we could figure out how scan beta is
formulated it process yeah that would be
really nice considering all the research
you were supposed to do on that subject
I thought you would have known something
about it so we heard of the concept of
jinxing have you sorry I forgot your
people my people what do you mean by my
people how dare you future lady I'm a
very sophisticated caveman from the 21st
century and also how dare you okay can i
plug this in movie to be able to move
bank okay so what did that do ma'am
check wow that's a lot of memory
terabytes of memory I guess it would be
in the 22nd century
oh man only 900 terabytes of RAM has
been corrupted oh crap reduce memory
footprint okay what do we not need okay
objects soma human mod lake wow this is
cool
so I need to remove some things what are
the biggest things Sun noon we owning
that many Suns well maybe we need some
Suns I want a full moon we don't need a
cloudy day we need them full moon uh
foliage I never liked foliage anyway get
that Sun in there don't need a river but
we need this I need that cabin a boat
boats are stupid dirt roads we can do
without that physics and added heat
dying light interface skin what are
these things
I can't even remove the forest let's see
we don't need fluid physics it's too
much
oh no we require that so we need all the
system things ok so those are things we
need but I want the cabin ok we don't
need a lake what god dammit ok we don't
need the Sun I guess we need that man
that's so picky why is it being so picky
such a stupid ok I guess huh ha ha ha
got ya I solved the puzzle I did it I
did it I can even add some more stuff
cuz apparently I don't need all that
crap that's what about the cabin not too
much what about
a bench I could have a bench I can have
a bench and basic vegetation I love it
it's awesome maybe even a chair I can
have a chair
all right cool I did it I have all this
cool stuff that shouldn't be that
difficult
I just want to make sure I understand
how the scan data is formulated before
we start messing around with the real
arm
okay how about him in animation and then
he hit pause while the code is running
it'll give me a cross-section of the
process better not use real data I don't
want to repeat what we did to Brandon
okay fine dummy okay dummy what about me
me ah
alrighty then sorry simulation
oh gosh should you pause well the dummy
is loaded oh is it can't know if it's
working or not okay oh oh I see
don't try again but that me needs to be
loaded when you pause there we go run
diagnosis they learned anything
I didn't thing with the science of
course so precise so perfect so perfect
I on your own work what oh right yeah
okay so are we good now did we do it we
done here can we go to Omicron and get
my new suit yeah yeah we should get
going I want to bring this Ark as a
backup now that wouldn't work this is
just a prototype good I prefer to try
the light let's go don't forget to take
me with you okay well not but I mean
it's still weird that I got a human
skeleton inside of this body and somehow
I'm able to control it like I don't
entirely understand how that works but I
do entirely understand that this
whatever this cancerous gross the weird
tentacle bluelight somehow is able to
adapt living tissue and that's really
bizarre what would it be able to move
and everything that seems to have a
personality has this growth on it
including my body all over it in fact I
mean the the did the done bad had it as
well so pretty much everything here does
thank you did you just sterilize me now
I can never have children hit okay so is
there anything special over here any
strings any bonus chests any
super-secret Easter eggs where does this
go anyway
well that's not what I would call a good
field who the hell is dingdong in my
phone
no no I'm busy shut up all right
anyway over to be able to move store got
out ahead I'm in sector all ready for
did you get everyone downstairs don't
worry about it
the stairs applaud and I killed the
elevator pull the connector chip in the
lock only way to keep you guys safe take
the shuttle go to Omicron good luck sir
tell us I love her dang knows the guy
that we were resurrecting in the last
episode that's really interesting where
are we now by an elevator ok so
apparently there's a monster wandering
around here and there's some needy blood
going over that away so maybe I should
go away from that for now hmm
boink Sarah how the hell are we gonna
make sure the art makes it every launch
is a crapshoot
you know look man I thought I could walk
away from it jeez Sarah how the hell are
we gonna make sure the art makes it
every lunch is a crapshoot you know
about I just wish these numbers
better what do you care it's just a pack
of data right yeah just a pack of data
yeah just a pack of data with the last
remnants of scans of humanity
okay whoa wait uh-huh alrighty then
someone was an artist that was leaving a
lot of paintings sir okay
payload I don't know what it means by
payload this looks dark okay caved in
over there
Oh was this where I saw the guy walking
around does that mean there's gonna be a
guy walking around very soon probably
okay so if those are health points I
don't need to touch all of them not
until I get damaged that's what I will
wait for what did I hear but I believe
the quantum whoa okay
okay oh wow oh god yeah yeah yeah yeah
what are we looking at here I mean
obviously we're looking at the fusions
of the the living tissue and whatever
this thing is doing to all of them but I
wish
oof I wish it was more data to this she
could have sat in on that conference
well it seems that I'm not alone around
here so I bet I'm gonna have a visitor
very very very soon oh good more blood
Oh
one of the worst cases I've seen it's
most likely his own damn fault he
blinded himself and clogged up his
intestines with structural structure gel
I'd be surprised if he ever woke up from
the coma did make me think of Hart's
absurd story about what happened at
lambda could it really be that the WoW
is somehow able to change and rebuild
the who heart appears to be in good
shape considering the circumstances only
bruised and mire and hypothermia caused
by the long walk it's difficult to
corroborate her story as she's the only
one to return as you will Chun is silent
is quiet and does her best to avoid eye
contact she doesn't want to be here but
Strohmeyer demands another evaluation
China is an obstinate or dishonest but
she'd rather not speak if it can be
avoided she has a hard time dealing with
people in general including doctors we
can character a perfect victim to be
dominated and pushed around by other she
is scared mouths I don't upset
Conrad his daddy boiled his brain to a
pulp with a W R M maser following the
arc neuro scan clearly another
continuity why why is this here are you
a person or you a thingy-thingy
ah are you the one that filled up your
intestines with structural gel ooh
tippy is broken remote remotely
controlled Oh Oh grody oh factor Delta
first unconscious water a 'christ is
clearly been consuming large amounts of
starch gel is probably difficult to tell
how this has affected his health beyond
the audience member and somehow
austerity gauja design
ah
[ __ ] you okay
okay oh my good
those are good sounds
where do I go where do I go I need to I
need to break this ah ah [ __ ] that
wasn't Leela sorry enough whoa
jeezum crow boy Oh any good
I don't know what to do all doctor on
guard I thought I was gonna be on a
feeling door crap yes like that
what the [ __ ] lose you old [ __ ] oh me oh
me oh my
oh me oh my oh me oh my
Oh God okay all right Oh
what the hell what happen to me what
happened to me what happened to me did
it get me
what happened what are you do to me what
did it do
oh I ain't doing so good a good thing
there's a Healey who right over here you
so there's something about the structure
gel that's able to reconstitute living
tissue I don't know what happened to me
god this is so weird I thought it I
thought it was gonna like I thought I
was gonna die in him
Oh God there he is again man how do I
get away from him
okay so I gotta get that door open
that's definitely a priority that I got
to do but I gotta get away from this guy
somehow and I gotta bring like an object
that I can actually use tub Bosch it
open jesus promised opening the doors is
kind of loud
there
I hear you Brandon what do you got Akers
and his critters are ferocious they pick
up on every move there's no way past
them then we'll find him we got to get
to the shuttle and out of us shake it
out us
no way listen I'll create a distraction
to pull them to me get the gangs to the
shuttle station wait Brandon what are
you doing
don't worry Alice back as soon as you
guys are safe just load up the shuttle
you're ready to go are you sure about
this I don't plan to die today sir see
the show well no one ever plans to die
on any given day except for select few
people but this is not interesting wait
no that's not what I meant at all this
very interesting but I mean this isn't
very helpful to my situation survived
the arc project stop people from killing
themselves send off seeing the team keep
people safe enjoy the rest of Armageddon
okay good to-do list
everyone needs goals alright we have
check the sealed doors move downstairs
shuttled omicron Akers is not alone at
least proxy creatures oh boy
sean has crossed off the lift which
means a Chun died at some point whew boy
that's not a good sound override door
lock okay uh maybe if I could trap it Oh
remaining resources none so okay so if I
okay what I need to do is they need to
lock doors down to be able to unlock
things okay so Omega management is open
and maybe if I could get in in one of
the rooms I could lock it in there oh
boy
but either way I just I opened up
another room I don't know where it is
okay oh oh oh oh oh oh oh not good
is it in the fence I do believe that
it's in the vents ah it's not good okay
so I gotta get to the room that I oh I
think this was in I think this might
have been the one I might have been able
to bust it open but maybe it's not a
good idea to keep that entire low Hey oh
no oh oh well hello there
how's it going friend oh why did it make
me do that
hello Brandon how's it going
Ravin
alrighty then oh boy well that was a
thing but at least I got a chip from him
which is gonna be used for something
that's gonna be explained a little bit
later what is that the moon why are they
getting a signal from the moon here okay
so I have a chip which means something I
don't know what but it sure does mean
something else okay not what I wanted
not what I wanted not what I wanted
whoa whoa whoa okay so where do I go now
and why are all the lights off why does
this has to be the way that it is where
am I going
I don't know where I'm going I have a
chip but I don't know what it's for
it might be for the door that was locked
in the beginning that I found I think it
was over here it might have been over
here over here is this it is this what I
needed 20 did yes that was it hope now
what
aspire chip I need to format the chip
how do I do that how do I do that
how do I Forge it's a specific way to do
that oh god oh god something not tough
right oh god oh god oh god
Oh kid Oh kid here we go okay in here
okay chip connector okay
loading loading loading go go go go go
go go go uh scaredy miss no not that key
control
update come on come on come on go okay
got it
did I do it I think I did okay got it
I'm out here I'm out baby I'm outtie I'm
Audi I got what I needed now yo Oh
oh maybe I do have a heart
considering it's coming down that way
which way you going buddy cuz I need to
plan another route to go come on what
are you doing
okay oh [ __ ] I think I'm okay okay I'm
gonna make it right to the door I'm not
gonna run I've got plenty of time
oh here we go here we go what it's
missing something what is it missing
clothes car whose clamps in panel still
network huh
slicing some good oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god what am i to close
clamps what does that mean Oh God
I don't know what closed clamps means oh
that that's what I need Scott dammit why
didn't either okay I did it I did it I
did it
rotor maintenance okay I'm out of here
Jesus just get out of my face you
[ __ ] why do they have to be such an
ordeal oh why did I have to close I
didn't know I needed to close the clams
that didn't seem very obvious to me why
am I here not cooperating with me ah why
is my life such a panicked blur at all
times
huh as a nightmare for multiple reasons
okay anyway alright so happy
please tell me that thing jumped down
and landed on top of me that would be
super fun super duper duper fun oh okay
well then alright goodbye elevator don't
close oh there was a chance I could have
grabbed oh I could have grabbed it I
didn't see that there was like no time
to react damn it how am i sore how am I
in pain that doesn't make any sense I
could have grabbed it it was like right
there damn it I didn't know though okay
now I'm good but I'm slightly dabbling I
wonder if I actually could have made
that out without any damage being taken
give me an alien butthole give me a
cyber butthole to shove my fist in do
anybody oh I heard the slippy slappy
sounds of footsteps I didn't know Oh God
whoa whoa okay
don't it's okay what it's over now relax
Ashley what are you doing here hey you
know like couples do all right you don't
want me yes of course
yep what happen
oh okay what's that all about I'm
guessing it tried to integrate me to the
well but because I'm mostly machine a I
don't have worked okay that was really
bizarre that was really really weird I
imagine that was supposed to happen like
I don't think I could have been able to
get away from that because like I was I
was already damaged from the fall it's
not like I had anywhere to run so I'm
pretty sure it was supposed to grab me
like that so anyway that's all the time
I have for this episode thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the entries for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
oh really amaze out